[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
bienvenue aux téléspectateurs de tv 78
bienvenue aussi aux auditeurs de radio
sensations qui nous ont rejoints depuis
quelques semaines et que nous soyons
bien bas alors nous avons beaucoup
d'intervenants aujourd'hui de très
grande qualité mais nous avons aussi des
sujets de très grande qualité puisque
gens leur parler de l'état vous savez
qu'on a un état qui est assez protecteur
mais est ce que c'est un état qui est
ses moteurs dans dans l'économie on va
parler de ce sujet on va parler aussi de
la réforme de l'ena on va parler de la
réforme de la justice et pour parler de
tous ces sujets jacques les lieux
mathilde obino bonjour et merci de nous
rejoindre vous êtes spécialité
communication vous habitez la ville du
chesnay
arthur de vannes bonjour mon jean
patrice bouchon à tous vous êtes ancien
élève de l'ena et vous êtes le président
du projet vauban vous êtes aussi élu
l'élu local à maisons laffitte et le
projet bobos on va en parler s'est
notamment exprimée par une tribune dans
le figaro justement dans lequel vous
appelez un état revenir à un état fort
un état qui son mot à dire dans
l'économie notamment dans la gouvernance
de l'économie vincent couronne bonjour
bonjour patrick bonjour à tous et ça va
bien vous êtes le fondateur des
surligneurs et si je croyais qu'elle
avait voix pardon j'ai oublié par dan
charlène bezina bonjour comment ça va
bonjour patron jean tout le monde est là
vous êtes maître de conférences de droit
public à l'université de rouen et puis
sur le plateau jean charles lajoie ni
bonjour vous êtes toujours éditeurs
toujours conduit au bras de votre
dernière livraison en fin d'émission et
laurent basauri bonjour bonjour vous
êtes
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines maire-adjoint
des locaux président de télé 78 et on va
commencer si vous devenez bien par
parler de l'état ce qu'est ce que c'est
que c'était assez vrai qu'on a un état
très protecteur on l'a vu il ya le
chômage partiel il ya les aides aux
entreprises mais
est ce que c'est un état qui intervient
à c est ce qu il faudrait revenir un
état plus forte arthur douanes
vous êtes l'auteur de cette tribune un
des auteurs de cette tribune des projets
vos beaux explique de nouveau deux mots
par le projet heureusement c'est une
initiative qui regroupe des jeunes
vingtenaires trentenaire de toute la
france des banlieues des campagnes des
grandes villes qui viennent à la fois du
secteur privé avec des entrepreneurs des
élus locaux des responsables associatifs
et des experts autour dans le fond d'une
idée simple c'est le refus du déclin 75
% des français pensent que la france est
en déclin et malheureusement ils ont
raison si on regarde sur le long terme
on s'est affaiblie donc ceux des classes
mais moins fort qu'avant et face à cela
il ya une génération qui se dit bon on
va pas rester dans la dictature du
présent on va pas se laisser enfermer
par les sujets des masques des vaccins
des pénuries de toutes sortes on se
prend trois cents jours avant la
présidentielle pour essayer d'imaginer
un programme pour sortir du déclin alors
c'est le premier thème de cette émission
faut-il réformer l'état
alors dans le texte qui a été publié
dans le figaro il ya cette phrase plus
la france est ouverte à la
mondialisation plus elle a renoncé à cet
état stratège pour un état sauveteurs
alors l'état sauveteurs c'est vrai dans
mazaury on le voit oui là on le voit
actuellement parce qu'on est dans des
décisions concrètes après je suis pas
certain que le sauvetage fassi réussi
que sartre ou cayenne tentative de
sauvetage on va dire mais en même temps
je trouve qu'on ne doit pas confondre
les choses c'est pas parce qu'on souvent
la mondialisation que forcément il ya
moins d'états l'état est là aussi pour
la piloter pour l'accompagner pour
permettre que les entreprises françaises
soient compétitives c'est pas moins
d'état c'est plus détaillée le mieux
d'état qu'il faudrait lité c'est arthur
dan c'est ce que vous dites il faudrait
un état faudrait revenir au fond à cet
état qui était essentiel dans les dom
dans les trente glorieuses quoi en fait
si vous voulez on vit dans un paradoxe
et on l'état fonctionne à l'envers c'est
à dire que l'état s'est alourdi en bas
et il s'est complètement à l'éclaireur
où il a perdu sa force stratégique et sa
force de vision d'investissement de
protection en eau et d'une certaine
façon le paradoxe est flic de la manière
suivante c'est que on s'est ouvert la
mondialisation en s'ouvrant à la
mondialisation sans avoir de stratégie
et sans savoir exactement ce qu'on
voulait pour la france on a perdu de
l'industrie c'est très simple il y avait
six millions d'emplois dans les années
70 il y en a 3 millions aujourd'hui et
la vérité c'est que l'emploi propublica
pratiquement augmenté dans les mêmes
proportions donc ce qu'on avait comme
économie productive avant on l'a replacé
par de l'économie non marchande pas
toujours très productive pas toujours
même avec les 35 heures qu'ils soient
respectés et symétriquement l'état en
eau donc les forces d'état-major qu'on
aimerait avoir
dans les ministères on aimerait avoir
dans les négociations internationales
qu'on aimerait avoir pour dire à la
commission européenne que nous on va pas
appliquer un certain nombre de règles
qui plombe notre industrie cette force
là on l'a perdu et donc ce qu'il
faudrait c'est en fait changer
complètement le paradigme c'est à dire
plus d'état au moins d'état en bas on
lâche tout en bas et on lâche rien c'est
un peu sage et iphone s'il ya plus de
décentralisation si je peux dire et et
plus de force de gouvernance de la part
de l'état c'est ça en fait si vous
prenez ce que font les états unis et
bien dans le fond il faut faire trump
plus belles dames voilà c'est à dire que
trump s'est dit oui effectivement la fin
de la naïveté dans les négociations
commerciales internationales
on arrête de laisser la chine faire nous
s'est désolé c'est lamentable ça fait ça
fait 30 ans qu'on se laisse marcher
dessus la moitié des entreprises du cac
40 sont détenus par des fonds étrangers
c'est le cas de pechiney qui a été
racheté par le canadien alcan c'est le
cas de arcelor qui a été racheté par
mittal sais pas si vous avez vu la peine
dix jours
holcim qui avait racheté lafarge a
purement et simplement rayé le mot
lafarge des statuts c'est à dire qu'ils
ont fait disparaître d'un trait de plume
150 ans d'histoire industrielle
française c'est ça je veux dire ça ça
c'est de l'aspect positif du train
doucement et l'aspect positif qui achève
hayden c'est l'investissement la
puissance publique la transformation
écologique voiliers et donc quand je dis
quand je dis plus d'état je suis pas en
train de dire plus d'impôts plus de
réglementations plus de lourdeur
bureaucratique au contraire la
transformation de l'état c'est justement
d'avoir l'état stratège qui défend la
france en eau et l'état n'y verrez
qu'ils laissent les français à respirer
en marre donc plus d'état - de recracher
s'il voulait j'avais dit dans quelle est
votre réaction c'est proposition
je la trouve en effet salutaire comment
ne pas être séduite par ses idées en les
entendant il ya il ya en effet un
constat de réforme de l'état qui
s'enlise en réalité depuis les années 60
se succèdent des réformes de l'état des
réformes de la gouvernance des
modernisation de l'état et pourtant
chacune d'entre elles amènent à chaque
fois à ne pas repenser les cadres de la
gouvernance mais plutôt à des mesures
sectorielles qui rajoute encore des
missions à l'état donc moi j'ai le
sentiment en effet qu'on a peut-être mon
ce col berthe isme très français
c'est-à-dire cette impression que notre
état ne s'est pas fonctionner sans un
formalisme se crée un enfermement qui
est très souvent décrié et ça c'est vrai
que c'est la logique bureaucratique qui
est quand même remise en cause depuis au
moins les années 80 mais dont on a du
mal à se défaire quant à la question
d'avoir un état pilotes c'est vrai que
quand on a renoué en tout cas l'année
dernière avec l'idée de créer un
commissariat général au plan cette idée
de réinstaller la gouvernance dans
quelque chose de plus prospectif et de
finalement plus
stratège ça me paraît être une bonne
chose sachant qu emmanuel macron
d'ailleurs dans sa réforme de l'état qui
était cap 20-22 2022 avait été le
premier à redire qu on devait renouer
avec l'état investisseurs retrouver un
petit peu les lettres de noblesse de
notre état décisionnaires et on s'est
rendu compte encore que le vecteur de la
réforme de l'état n'était finalement pas
le bout pour arriver jusque-là donc est
ce que ce n'est finalement plus une des
taux une réforme des méthodes de l'état
des méthodes de la gouvernance dont on
aurait besoin plus que d'une énième
réforme de la décentralisation d'une
nouvelle loi sur l'état général on sait
plus à l'état de prendre conscience de
ses responsabilités pour arriver à se
réformer lui même le type domino
un problème non vincent couronne adam
vincent louis
vuitton très bien patrice persie en fait
je suis assez d'accord avec le constat
sur le fait qu' on déshabille un
effectivement le
dire les pilotes n'y voyait rien de le
monde est ravi surtout de sauver de
l'état en réalité et qu'est ce qui se
passe est très très fréquemment enfin
manière générale ces dernières années
lorsqu'on parle de réformer l'état
en réalité ça signifie de moderniser
l'état c'est souvent ce qui se cache
derrière aux réformes et ce n'est pas
que modernisé s'est aussi adaptée à un
certain défi quand on parle de
moderniser en réalité derrière ça cache
beaucoup de dématérialisation de
numérisation et c'est pour économiser
des postes et au final on supprime des
postes de pilotes tout simplement parce
qu'on estime que les tâches qui faisait
auparavant que leurs assistants les
gestionnaires faisait auparavant sont
toujours peuvent être aujourd'hui
dématérialisée je donne pas un seul
exemple c'est l'université aujourd'hui à
l'université et anne charlene elle
pourra pas me contredire là dessus
on a on a enchaîné matérialiser tout un
tas de procédure que du coup on a confié
qu'on a confiées aux enseignants
chercheurs ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui ce
sont les enseignants chercheurs qui
rentrent les notes sont les enseignants
chercheurs qui en dirigeant les masters
s'occupe de tout un tas de tâches
administratives qu'il n'avait pas géré
auparavant conséquence lorsqu'il ya une
crise ou lors qu'on veut réformer et
bien c'est ses pilotes en quelque sorte
ne sont plus disponibles
pour pouvoir vous fait faire les
mouvements les changements qui sont
nécessaires à faire de fournir les
efforts nécessaires la crise sanitaire
l'a très bien montré comment est ce que
l'université vous voulez qu'elle se sent
qu'elle ce qu'elle soit prête ou que les
enseignants chercheurs à l'université
soit en mesure de pouvoir rapidement se
réformer pouvoir gérer la crise alors
qu'en fait nous même quasiment même plus
le temps de faire propre métier du fait
de leur ville de l'arrondissement le
tout c'est daschle a donc il y a par
cette dématérialisation en fait derrière
un objectif qui est celui de réduire le
nombre de postes au sommet de l'état
et forcément mais quand quand il faut
réformer il n'y a plus il ya plus de
disponibilité humaine on le voit
aujourd'hui on fait appel beaucoup à la
sous traitance
avec cabinet de conseils voire j'étais
justement ces cdd crise où des réformes
voilà donc ça c'est ça c'est notamment
carrière le syndicaliste
celle là je dis moi je suis assez
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire
monsieur dehaene à ceci près que juste
un petit correctif l'histoire de lafarge
je pense que la ce pour une fois c'est
plutôt une bonne idée parce que si on
enlève le nom de la farce et aussi parce
que j'ai cette histoire est que l'état
islamique qui n'est pas quand même une
très bonne idée donc là pour une fois on
va pas se plaindre que ce nom
disparaissent ça c'est une chose après
will et l'état c'est très bien mais
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec cette
idée trump hayden s'est bien lutté
contre la chine c'est bien c'est une
évidence après ce que tout est de la
faute de l'état est-ce qu'il ya aussi le
de
la france et des français qui sont aussi
la société eda société kim n'est pas
peut-être non plus toujours prête à
faire les efforts qu'on est en droit
d'attendre d'elle et que et que ça peut
aussi ruiner toute envie de d'installer
des choses en france et c'est encore
vraiment on peut comprendre que l'état
ou pas et à un gros industriels ou des
gros investisseurs se dit finalement et
c'est peut-être beaucoup plus simple
d'aller ailleurs que dès son enfance
donc c'est pas qu'une possibilité
délocalisations c'est juste est ce que
les choses sont faisable en france
c'était ça le vrai problème plus que et
à outreau d'état que peut-on vraiment
faire en france alors laurent mazuray
sur la notion d industrialisation dont
l'état serait la cause n'oublions pas
que le rôle des politiques en général
parce que ce qui pose problème
aujourd'hui ce qui amène les entreprises
à délocaliser ses grande partie pour des
raisons de coûts de production et quand
je parle de coûts de production je
parlerai partie des charges et les
charges sociales vont avec un état mais
un état au sens large et avec ce qu'on a
bâtie comme projet citoyen aujourd'hui
et l'assistance qui apporte l'état mais
sur décision des politiques auprès entre
autres du début des plus démunis
l'assistance et du côté matelas de
sécurité c'est un coup ce coup il est
porté sur les entreprises et une partie
des missions dévolues socialisation je
pense à la production des moteurs en
hongrie dont on dit aujourd'hui youpi on
va réouvrir localisées ont été cette
édition qui est fausse puisqu'une partie
des moteurs partent quand même on en
garde pain on regarde pas les autres
puisqu'ils vont certainement brille à
côté des bridgestone mais pourquoi
vont-ils saturn ont dit parce que le
coût de production hongrie est moins
élevée et par l'état c'est aux yeux
des producteurs français ça a des
chances d'être à valenciennes non mais
on voit bien la problématique certes
l'état à un coût de fonctionnement mais
c'est pas le coût de fonctionnement de
l'état qui pèse le plus c'est des
décisions politiques où la demande est
d'assumer en redistribuant manière plus
importante que dans d'autres pays une
partie effectivement de ce que les
entreprises peuvent produire faut pas
non plus oublier ce moment là je pense
arthur de m est-ce qu'il ya pas quand
même dans cette tribune et dans cette
volonté du projet vauban une vision un
peu mythique de l'état c'est vrai que y
ait eu cet état des années 60 et agolli
avec l'ardente obligation du plan qui
était en effet le moteur de l'économie
mais si ça a disparu c'est aussi parce
que les entreprises se sont
se sont libérés de la tutelle de l'état
c'est parce que il ya il ya eu le marché
quand même qui a changé un peu les
choses
j'allais à une philosophe vont beaucoup
qui est simone veil et qui disait la
france était capable de renouveau tout
en étant fidèle à son génie je
m'explique
lorsqu'on parle de réformer la france on
évoque tout le temps margaret thatcher
guérin fraudeurs le fn comme si dans le
fond on ne pouvait trouver de salut qu
en s'inspirant 116 ce qui se fait
ailleurs les allemands ont fait
effectivement dans les années 2000
quelque chose de très fort mais qui
l'est c'est quelque chose qui est
conforme à leur façon de faire de
l'économie alors à leur histoire à leur
génie propre de la même manière que
margaret thatcher au royaume-uni bon sur
une sur une île où le libéralisme a été
inventé ces cas étonnant si vous voulez
que les choses ont été faites de cette
manière là moi ce que je crois c'est
qu'en france
d'abord avant de parler d'état on peut
peut-être parler de service public et le
service public à la française c'est
quelque chose qui existe c'est quelque
chose qui peut être efficace et de ce
point de vue là je prends un exemple ça
a été dit tout à l'heure en parlant de
l'université prenez l'administration de
la santé c'est hallucinant c'est à dire
que en bas vous avez un tiers des
effectifs qui sont des administratifs
vous avez des hôpitaux qui sont à la
fois ci je suis équipé et surchargé en
personnel pour ainsi dire trop le trot
d'administratifs en bas et lorsque vous
prenez
duquesne c'est à dire le ministère de la
santé est bien là vous n'avez pas grand
pas grand monde vous avez sept mille
personnes au total pour toute la france
les laboratoires son plein tout le monde
s'en plaint vous avez une sous
administration qui est complètement
rachitique et on est obligé de faire
appel à mckinsey pour élaborer le plan
de logistique de distribution des
vaccins oui c'est ça que je veux dire
par on a trop d'état en bas et pas assez
des temps et pour répondra à la question
est-ce que c'est un mythe ou pas non
c'est pas un mythe c'est simplement
qu'il faut faire comme comme ce qu'on
fait dans les entreprises c'est à dire
où s'asseoir regarde ce qui fonctionne
on regarde ça ne fonctionne pas et on
essaie d'en faire de cette crise une
opportunité parce que moi ce dont j'ai
peur c'est que la réforme soit la
victime du comider c'est à dire que les
français aient tellement peur de
l'avenir soit tellement inapte à se
projeter et on les comprend bien
puisqu'on sait même pas de quoi la
semaine prochaine sera faite qu'en fait
ils renoncent à toute idée de
réforme de remise en ordre de la nation
or c'est une condition et c'est ce que
disait à jean-charles à venise c'est ce
sont des changements on va devoir faire
et ça il faut que les politiques le
disent
cela dit que vous disiez vous parliez de
derrière de thatcher de ceux de la
france a toujours été un peu à contre
temps je dire quand le monde devenait
libéral avec l'acteur oriane nous on est
disait mitterrand quand il ya les
populistes qui arrivent nous on élit
macron fait que c'est plutôt européen on
regarde quand même le seul autre temps
par rapport aux autres pays non oui mais
parce que je pense qu'il ya
il comment dire depuis les disons que le
monde des trente glorieuses je vous en
parlais tout à l'heure correspondait
très bien à ce que spontanément la
france savait faire
les cinquante années de mondialisation
que vient de traverser nous laisse
encore déboussolés on n'a toujours pas
trouvé notre modèle notre voix
françaises dont la mondialisation et moi
je le crois que la bonne solution c'est
pas de choisir entre marine le pen et
jean luc mélenchon qui ont programme
économique de la cgt soit clair et
l'espèce de rom d'europe et mondial aux
béatitudes qui consiste à avoir un
regard complètement fasciné sur le
village global en trouvant que les
français sont quand même bringue avec
certains villages de loi pour dérisoire
je crois qu'il faut il faut prendre ce
qui est bon dans les deux c'est à dire
dans dans la vision populiste il ya
quand même l'idée que oui l'état peut
faire quelque chose oui la france doit
se défendre oui il faut qu'on arrête de
se laisser faire dans le monde actuel et
puis essayer de prendre l'aspect la
dimension de modernité dont on a besoin
ce qu'il faut pas qu'on renonce à notre
autre à notre puissance on existe mais
la sixième puissance mondiale et c'est
pas à la hauteur de la france que de ne
pas avoir de vaccins on va il faut
changer ça et il faut pas baisser les
bras parce que je pense que derrière 7,7
ce non choix démocratique qui va nous
être proposées certainement en 2022 il
ya en réalité plutôt l'exigence à 1 an à
moins d'un an du premier tour des
élections présidentielles d'imaginer ce
qu'il faut être un programme fluide et
que vous avez un candidat pour l'interné
bah y'en à la fois trop et pas assez
mais c'est je pense que si vous voulez
elle l'a
la maladie française mais qui nous vient
de cette époque où bonaparte s'y est
imposé dans le tumulte de la guerre
civile française à la révolution c'est
que plus ou moins qu'il ya trop de gens
dans ce pays qui veulent être président
cheval public dans le soit il a un trop
plein de gens qui se disent tiens
pourquoi pas moi
alors alors on reste est
la première des étapes c'est pas l'homme
providentiel c'est le citoyen
providentiel essayons de faire l'effort
le privé le public
l'entreprise l'associatif les
collectivités locales de converger sur
un certain nombre de sujets et là ça
peut marcher n'ai-je pas que le manque
de consensus dans la construction d'un
programme présidentiel et on est encore
trop dans le rapport de forces est à mon
avis c'est là où la france doit sa paie
des impôts c'est laurent manoury que
tous les sondages de 10 va y avoir un
coup bas marine le pen contre contre
macron or les français c'est parce que
vous les français en même temps c'est
parce qu'ils souhaitent alors je pense
que c'est parce qu'ils souhaitent et
bien souvent la politique d'intérêt ce
malheureusement que les politiciens une
des manières de faire en sorte que les
français s'intéressent à la politique
c'est justement de parler du fond et je
trouve que bien souvent dans nos
émissions parle plus du fond que serait
déjà entendre ailleurs et là il y aurait
effectivement matière voyez par exemple
quand j'entends parler du commissaire au
plan moi j'allais être le premier à le
saluer en disant voilà on revient alors
il ya le côté c'était mieux avant que je
pense que c'est moi que ça il y avait en
fait comme dans une entreprise on fixe
une stratégie on commence par c'est une
stratégie qu un plan à cinq ans dix ans
on voit ensuite son comment on peut le
décliner mais c'est pas juste la
stratégie ensuite on met les différents
wagons importants dont le commissaire au
plan il a sa valeur si effectivement
derrière on fixe et stratégiques on s'y
tient sur la partie hindoue riel parce
que ce qui fait la force d'un pays on
peut dire ce que l'on veut c'est sa
capacité à les capter des devises pour
financer l'ensemble de ses programmes si
on reste franco-français et qu'on sait
pas prendre le train de la
mondialisation se disant pas je vous
donne un exemple quand j'entends dire
que la stratégie par exemple c'est la
transition écologique
suite tha ok très bien super allons-y
mais concrètement c'est quoi est ce que
j'entends derrière dire ça serait on a
une stratégie sur l'hydrogène parce que
quand le général de gaulle on a le
succès on peut critiquer néanmoins en
l'état le moins carboné du monde grâce à
toi dead entre énergie nucléaire mais ça
a été aussi un succès industriel
extraordinaire ça sous tendue également
la portée des transports donc tout ça
c'est que des décisions politiques et l
indépendance énergétique on peut
retrouver effectivement sur l'énergie la
transition et caudry mais ça suffit pas
ça c'est le marketing l'arrêté derrière
c'est que pour que des élus soit élu il
faut qu'ils portent un projet et j'en
viens à votre question patrice si on
doit choisir entre marine le pen et même
un accro je suis désolé xavier bertrand
et d'autres parce que c'est ce que les
journalistes veulent nous faire croire
c'est tu vas forcément à abolir les
sondages d'aujourd'hui dont tu auras
l'année prochaine on a vu dernièrement
que
j'en sais rien marine le pen a peut-être
acheter des chaussures ont bien hâte est
offert mais l'attaquante et des costumes
que sais-je encore néanmoins le fond du
sujet demeure c'est à dire est ce que
dans ce pays on peut prendre conscience
que pour s'en sortir il faut avoir une
activité industrielle et commerciale
forte qui a effectivement dont le mood
globale que l'on s'est fixée la
stratégie si c'est la transition
écologique so what allons-y mais à y
ayons la politique industrielle derrière
elle a les français le suivront si on
fait que des vains mots et qu'on
explique qu'il faut faire la transition
en achetant embêtant des éoliennes dans
des espaces classés magnifique et plan
étant des panneaux solaires qui sont
fabriqués majoritairement chine à
l'école du coude génère pas d'emplois en
france mais ça ne marchera pas il faut
que ça génère une économie enfin
majoritairement en france oui juste un
petit mot sur sont encore une fois
arthur de m
il ya encore trois mois la france donc
l'état français essayait de vendre le
fleuron de l'industrie
des bateaux des chantiers chantier naval
avec fincantieri qu'on voulait vendre
aux italiens mais la chantier qui marche
qui est bénéficiaire ont fait les plus
gros paquebot du monde les plus beaux et
ça fait quatre ans que l'état essaye de
vendre ce selon pour des raisons mais
absolument abracadabrantesque genou
c'était absolument insensé et on veut
vendre cela il reste déjà plus grand
chose en france qu on fabrique on arrive
à faire des bateaux qu'on regarde ça
aberrant mais on nous a persuadé c'est
là johnny qu'en france la justice était
fini il y avait plus de la matière grise
choses d'ici là puisqu'on parlait des
nappes ce qu'on avait largement parlé je
me demande si les vous à français à des
nappes se voit tout mais alors je reçois
des stagiaires de désengorger
professionnelle
dans un sens vient cette idée juste un
bout peut-être ramsar aide 7 cette
vision assez forte à ses parfois
peut-être me dis que de l'état est ce
que ça ne vient pas aussi du fait que en
france l'état a précédé la nation vous
est donné comme historique importante
c'est une donnée historique qui se
discute également parce que le sentiment
national il est très distincts en tout
cas dans la conception française qu'on à
la nation de l'état et je suis pas sûr
que nous ayons eu un état avant d'avoir
une nation parce que la nation c'est
quand même le sentiment du vivre
ensemble et ça ça moi je ne suis pas
certain qu historiquement il a été
précédé et je ne sais pas si c'est
vraiment une donnée en tout cas de notre
force ou de notre faiblesse de l'état
néanmoins ce sur quoi je pense qu'il est
important aussi de réagir c'est qu'on
nous avons très souvent l'idée que
l'état devrait s'adapter avec la même
souplesse que le droit privé que
l'entreprise etc je crois qu'au
contraire est à la fois cc c'est aussi
ce que je perçois dans le discours qui
nous est donnée aujourd'hui c'est que il
y à un grand danger à manager réalisé
absolument l'état comme nous le faisons
depuis finalement 30 ans en
en essayant de calquer la fonction
publique sur le droit du travail de
calquer droit de l'organisation
territoriale sur des entreprises mères
et filiales je crois qu'il faut quand
même aussi garder à l'état sa
particularité sa puissance et justement
je rejoins ce discours de puissance
puisque je pense que si on s'inspire
trop de cette souffler ces cons et qu'on
allège sans arrêt l'état on va aussi
risquer de manquer de service public de
pouvoir de décision donc il ya il ya
aussi ce paradoxe très français entre
l'état providence et l'état libéral qui
fait aujourd'hui son identité et qui
fait aujourd'hui son endettement
historique mais je crois nécessairement
qu'il ne faut pas sacrifier l'un ou
l'autre mais qu'il faut choisir la voix
de mme équilibre entre tous ces
paradoxes le privé le public
le libéralisme et le social et c'est
peut être ça aussi qui fait cette
exception française dont monsieur
domaine parlait si bien en tout cas ça
sera sans doute comme le dj laurent
natori un débat important de la
prochaine présidentielle on va passer
cet autre sujet emmanuel macron après
avoir hésité à annoncer la suppression
de l'ena c'est notre deuxième sujet
[Musique]
d'abord on va aller faire un petit tour
dans la rue thiers qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce qu'on pense les personnes que nous
avons interrogées
[Musique]
pensent que tous les gens du
gouvernement ils viennent de là-bas du
coup ma parole c'est mieux si baisse il
supprime cette école il y aura plusieurs
comment dire il peut venir de plusieurs
écoles et y aura plusieurs universités
et sera mieux à priori oui parce que mon
sentiment c'est que la haute
administration
un petit peu trop de pouvoirs ou prend
peu trop de place dans les dents les
décisions qui sont prises par les uns ou
les autres je serais pour qu'il y ait
une autre
a sion qui accueille
des gens de ils ont d'origine et de
formation très diverses est quand même
très dommage que tous les cadres
d'administration soient issus de cette
école eux mêmes issus des sciences pour
la question ce serait plutôt si on veut
supprimer l'ena pour éviter un
renouvellement des élites du même
endroit
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça serait ce
qui le remplacerait et est-ce que ça
corrigerait le problème du
renouvellement je suis contre la
suppression de l'ena pour moi c'est un
gage d'excellence et une spécificité une
spécificité c'est et française et je
serai ça dommage de supprimer cette
institution d'excellence je pense que ça
va dépendre justement des des mises en
oeuvres qui seront qui seront déposées
est ce que ce sera véritablement une
refonte ou alors un saupoudrage est ce
qu'il y aura véritablement d'aider des
propositions concrètes sur sur la
possibilité d'ouvrir le champ des des
candidats et d'avoir justement cette
efficacité pour combiner la formation
des futurs hauts fonctionnaires c'est ça
qui importe ah non parce que j'adorais
compter s'il y aille arthur dehaene je
m'adresse à vous en premier puisque vous
êtes aussi un élève de l'ena
comment vous avez vécu alors cette idée
de la suppression on en parle depuis
très longtemps quand même
nom mais si vous voulez je trouve que
les legends l'interroger dans le micro
trottoir ont la bonne réaction et il
montre un peu que les gouvernants
sous-estiment l'intelligence des
français se trouvent parce que là ce qui
a été dit
majoritairement c'est oui mais c'est
pour faire quoi tout dépend de ce qu'on
fera après donc ça veut dire qu'un ils
sont pas coupe le changement mais que
deux ils veulent qu'on leur propose un
chemin ils veulent qu'on leur dise voilà
ce qu'on va faire et pas simplement
qu'on leur donne le scalp des élites
parce que c'est pas parce qu'il ya plus
d na qui aura plus d'élites il y aura
toujours des élites essais et c'est la
vérité depuis l'antiquité donc faut pas
faire de démagogie c'est pas parce qu'on
supprime les n'a que tout d'un coup on a
mis le peuple au pouvoir
lena serait remplacé par un institut du
service public interne bezina ça serait
peut-être pas mal c'est vrai que ça va
ouvrir alors dans cet institut service
public du ray les polytechniciens il y
aurait d'autres écoles etc mais c'est
vrai que d'ouvrir l'administration par
exemple vous vous êtes vous êtes en cinq
ans dans l'enseignement supérieur si
vous vous proposer par exemple je sais
pas de dead d'aller dans la préfectorale
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui vous
pourrez vous tenter non mais c'est vrai
qu'on pourrait ouvrir les les les
possibilités d'emploi dans la fonction
publique non alors je vais d'abord
patrice pour répondre à la question de
la suppression des nappes qui je vous
parlerai ensuite de l'évolution de ma
carrière personnelle
j'ai le sentiment en fait que la
suppression glénat s'est à nouveau je
partage complètement ce qui a été dit
par messieurs de nc c'est un peu de la
poudre aux yeux c'est à dire qu'on on a
le sentiment il faut rappeler quand même
que c'est une politique de suppression
de l'ena qui est installé dans le
discours d' emmanuel macron depuis la
crise des gilet jaune et qu'il a eu le
sentiment qu'en fait c'était une réponse
à une crise sociale et à cette crise
sociale il a voulu en quelque sorte
décapité le roi en se disant pas au
moins si je supprime ce serait cette
école des élites on aura le sentiment je
suis plus proche de la base et je
partage complètement le point de vue la
suppression cette école de grains
nécessairement passer par la création
d'une autre et on retrouvera donc
évidemment la question de la formation
des années auprès des futurs
administrateurs surtout qui
passera évidemment par une école l'autre
question c'est est-ce que les nacres et
l'énarchie alors on est des super
article 2 de nos plus grands penseurs
français sur ces questions et à nouveau
je pense qu'en effet les mythes n'est
pas du tout un mal français et que c'est
au contraire une très bonne chose
d'avoir une élite et que c'est une très
bonne chose d'avoir une élite très
formée et je rejoins complètement le
propos de monsieur de haine qui va
d'ailleurs avec la tergiversation
d'emmanuel macro c'est à dire que on n'a
pas besoin de supprimer les nains on a
besoin de réformer à nouveau mais avec
le sens propre de la réforme
c'est-à-dire reformer une base de
connaissances de manière de forger de
nouveaux administrateurs pour demain des
politiques qui soient à la fois divers
mais à la fois renseigné de toute notre
passion française etc donc il ya en
effet emmanuel mâcon qui nous dit qu'ils
suppriment puis emmanuel macron qui nous
dit qu'il va finalement changé la
formation à l'intérieur emmanuel macron
qui nous dit qu'il reçut prix donc en
fait je pense que le vrai problème c'est
celui de la formation et c'est celui des
métis mme du pantouflage est ce qu'on
est vraiment d'accord avec le fait que
nos politiques puissent quitter la
politique avec les dossiers politiques
pour partir ensuite dans l'industrie et
aidons et dans le privé il ya toutes ces
questions à poser mais qui sont des
questions morales des questions
d'éthique de transparence de gouvernance
et qui pour moi ne se suffiront pas
évidemment d'une d'une simple réforme et
d'une simple suppression et d'un
changement bon parce que celle ci s p ça
va être un nouvel ena mais il faut qu'on
retrouve certains fondamentaux de l'ena
à l'intérieur donc pourquoi refaire du
neuf avec de l'ancien quant à ma
carrière personnelle évidemment je
dirais oui à toutes nouvelles aventures
patrice donc la préfectorale etc je
connais donc est ce que vous voulez
l'inspection des finances de
jeu recèle de jeudi est ce qui est pas
un peu d'affichage comme ça antilles
élitisme symbole quoi un symbole mais
qui va pas être remplacé par quelque
chose de très différent absolument et
c'est un peu dommage mais disons que ça
fait partie d'une des promesses com - le
crédit en macro on peut tenir alors donc
là c'est presque du pain béni pour lui
et puis deuxièmement il ya sûrement
besoin de réformer un peu l'ena mais mon
sens le véritable problème c'est surtout
l'omniprésence des énarques qui est
gênante si dans les gouvernements si
dans les administrations n'y avait pas
que des énarques mais du coup les
énarques serait peut-être ferait
peut-être plus attention à ce qu'ils
disent s'ouvrir et un petit peu mais
alors que là ils sont élevées en
batterie entre eux et puis après on les
met dans des ministères ils sont tous
ensemble cela dit on avec sarkozy et
fillon n'avait c'était assez rare un
président républicain premier miss qui
n'était pas ancien élève de l'ena ça a
changé beaucoup de choses oui je trouve
à bord du convoi avec le président
suivant 1 800 à changer vous honnêtement
kate et anna on a vu la différence mais
mais surtout effectivement ni sarkozy ni
fillon n'était et marque mais ils
étaient entourés d'énarques parce que
des arcs y en a partout et mais si
l'état allait puiser dans un autre
vivier temps en temps si on avait plus
si on n'essaie pas tous les
polytechniciens aller dans le privé et
si tentants et des polytechniciens
écoles exceptionnel arrivé aux manettes
ça changerait aussi la donne ce serait
intéressant un des des axes de la
réforme si j'ai bien compris ce serait
de copier ce qui se fait dans l'armée
c'est à dire qu'il ya une promotion
interne voilà les colonels comme ça ils
montrent généralement c'est dans un sens
ou dans d anciens sous-officiers mais
qui est ou qui ont fait leurs preuves
sur le terrain c'est vrai qu'on pourrait
vincent couronne on pourrait ouvrir à
des fonctionnaires qui n'ont pas fait
l'ena dd deschamps plus haut de
responsabilité
oui c'est vrai que ça c'est un des
éléments intéressants de la réforme
c'est à dire supprimer le classement de
sortie et faire en sorte qu' il ya un
petit peu de terrain quelques années de
terrain avant de pouvoir ensuite monté
en grade
mais mais
ça va peut-être changer effectivement
une vision ou comment dire et des à la
une meilleure formation des et n'a
notamment parce que ce qui a été dit
tout à l'heure sur le fait
qu'effectivement ils n'ont ils n'ont pas
de culture industrielle ou peut-être
qu'en envoyant plus de terrain ils
seront ils seront notamment dans la
préfectorale ils se rendront un peu plus
compte des réalités du terrain mais il
ya probablement deux choses en fait qui
manque dans la formation à l'ena
je n'ai pas l'impression que dans la
réforme quelque chose qui soit vraiment
apporter c'est arrivé savoir gérer des
projets alors certes il faut pas copier
tout ce qui se fait dans le privé je
suis assez d'accord avec charlène bezina
sur ce point là on va pas importer dans
l'administration tout les toutes les
méthodes du privé parce que l'état aussi
a sa spécificité à préserver mais enfin
il faut quand même reconnaître que
notamment quand on regarde la gestion de
la crise sanitaire on se rend compte
qu'on a des personnes à la tête de
l'état qui sont incapables de gérer
comment dire ce genre de situation et
puis la gestion rh aussi là aussi où les
tailles gestion rh absolument
catastrophique et donc ces deux points
sur lesquels il faudrait probablement
qu'il y ait beaucoup plus d'ambition
après moi je ne suis pas forcément plus
compétent pour parler de ce sujet je je
je forme des cert et bien des candidats
aux différents concours administratifs
mais uniquement dans ma discipline
mais ce qui est assez révélateur c'est
que dans aucun des concours pour
lesquelles je forme les étudiants il y à
une épreuve justement de gestion de
projet
les choses dans aucun c'est
essentiellement des concours de
connaissances avec des qcm des concours
de culture générale et s'est fait ses
preuves de culture générale
mais où quelques cas pratique mais pas
beaucoup plus c'est ça quand même c'est
calme c'est problématique voilà j'ai pas
grand chose de plus à dire je suis
désolé patrice
je vais laisser plusieurs témoignages un
geste et pour conclure cette oui
j'ai le sentiment que peut-être quand on
parle trop des narcos on confond aussi
la
l'énergie avec la question des
entourages des présidents ou de
l'entourage des présidents et des
premiers ministres et des gouvernants en
général et je pense que là il ya quelque
chose qu'il faut qu'on dit c'est que on
est dans un état où on consulte trop on
externalise on sous traite ont créé des
comités où on fait participer des
échantillonnages de public mais on
décide plus et finalement je crois que
l'un des grands mots de cet état avec
cet entourage d'énarques c'est pas les
énarques eux mêmes c'est le fait qu'on
ait besoin d'un entourage pour décider
et c'est peut-être aussi cette question
que la réforme de l'ena à sous silence
et que pourtant le peuple a vraiment
besoin d'entendre retraités c'est que
fait-on de ses entourages des
décisionnaires est ce qu'ils sont
vraiment seul à décider qui les
conseillent et comment créer autour
d'eux finalement des milliers de gens
suffisamment renseigné de la base est
suffisamment renseigné les fondamentaux
pour créer une gouvernance démocratique
et qui est qu'ils soient aussi une
gouvernance de la décision c'est ça le
problème du roman the rye oui ça va
jouer notre premier thème en réalité je
trouve que es qu'une intervention de
parce qu'en réalité c'est quoi c'est que
une partie des politiques sont très bie
très content aussi d'avoir des énarques
aux tirs 2 très content de voir ainsi à
décisionnel très content de créer le
énième comité théodule parce que c'est
une forme de rld et responsabilisation
et de peur de la décision un moment
donné je me présente face à des
électeurs avec un programme j'assume mon
programme j'ai le droit aussi de me
tromper mais je l'assuré essayer de
trouver des faire valoir des prête-noms
qui vont justifier que où j'ai pas pu le
faire parce que mon mandat empêcher
c'est pas de ma faute ce sont les
énarques ou gelée mal fait mais pourtant
j'avais consulté le énième la nième
commission citoyenne mais les noms je
porte un projet je me suis effectivement
entourée d' expertise mais je me fais ma
propre opinion et en tant qu'élu je me
dois de la porter le témoignage souvent
d'anciens ministres qui sont pas des
énarques c'était c'est de dire à chaque
fois qu'ils proposaient quelque chose
qui avait quelqu'un de l'admistration
regret non non c'est pas possible en
même temps qu'est ce que vos instincts
elle témoigne aussi du thon rouge c'est
de dire merci dardé que c'était pas
possible c'est déjà aussi comment celle
ci et là on peut parler politique sinon
ben c'est qu'une démocratie et c'est
tout le problème il est là et juste de
terminer ce jeu me rappelle la
suppression également quand on a
supprimé les iufm on se dit super on a
réglé le problème on n'a rien rien du
tout on voit bien que la notion
suppression de l'ena c'est pas le sujet
le sujet effectivement que la dialyse la
bureaucratie et de ce qu'on a mis
apprend pardon national thomson rebondit
un mime sur ce que vous disiez pas pris
chez vivement le beaucoup de ministres
disent on prend des décisions puis on
nous dit c'est pas possible je rappelle
que le candidat macron avait promis de
faire une sorte d'audit de tous ces
directeurs d'administrations et
éventuellement de virer
cette action rappelle de politique vous
dégagez une s'est rien passé n'a rien
mais c'est peut-être une idée du spoil
system est pas totale ainsi nous paraît
totalement aberrantes comme ça dans la
tradition française
totalement totalement fausses un dernier
mot sur ce soutien et arthur donne
d'abord il faut rappeler qu'avant l'ena
il y avait des concours pour le quai
d'orsay pour la préfectorale et c'est
bon pour l'inspection des finances et
qu'au fond il y avait une reproduction
sociale ou peut-être plus forte que
l'ena et un effort de démocratisation
d'accès à la haute fonction publique
mais hélas la question que vous devez
vous demander puisque il ya en effet ce
problème du classement de sortie que
souvent les promotions même de l'ena
remettent en cause est ce que est ce qu
on a l'impression tout est joué à 25 ans
en fait il ya deux questions
fondamentales effectivement la première
c'est
l'égal accès de tous les français aux
emplois publics qui est en principe de
quais dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen était une question
de justice mais ça c'est pas
supprimer l'ena ou pas ne répond pas à
cette question là ça pose la question de
la méritocratie française de la base
jusqu'au sommet ça pose la question de
l'éducation nationale ça pose la
question de réinventer notamment par le
mentorat en attachant un mentor et un
jeune main dans la main vont de l'avant
pour essayer comme comme ça se faisait
sous la troisième république les
hussards noirs il prenait des gamins
dont il trouvé qu'ils avaient du talent
et les emmener au sommet louis germain
j'ai déjà dit légèrement c'était le
mentor d'albert camus
que vous voulez cette question là
doit se traiter à mon avis au delà du
seul cas de lennar voilà c'est gênant on
fait par ces partis delà de la question
mais ce n'est pas elle n'épuise pas la
conscience à ses premiers points et le
second point c'est celle de savoir
effectivement ce que l'on va apprendre à
nos élites et de ce point de vue là il
faut qu'on réalise la chance qu'on a en
france on a la chance de former nous
mêmes nos élites
les américains ne supprime pas avare de
les anglais ne supprime pas oxford et
prenez un pays comme la grèce ils
forment leurs élites à l'étranger même
note qu'elle n'importe quel gouvernement
de deux pays d'asie centrale d'afrique
même d'amérique latine forme leur zénith
à l'étranger il ya que quelques pays sur
terre qui forment souverainement leurs
élites donc c'est un élément de notre
souveraineté que de formes et de nous
mêmes nous dirigeants ça c'est très
important et donc la question c'est
patent est ce que je suis prêt mais ce
que je supprime pas assez
quelles sont mes besoins vous parlais
tout à l'heure monsieur coin de vous
parler de la gestion rh moi je suis
d'accord avec vous le fait d'anticiper
sur 20 ans quels vont être les besoins
d'une nation et de l'aider d'anticiper
en termes de gestion prévisionnelle des
emplois et des compétences et de te dire
je vais avoir besoin de x y et z
compétences donc je les transmets à
béziers dit c'est ça le questionnement
qu'il faut l'avoir ensuite moi je pense
que la suppression de l'un et est
certainement une nécessité parce que
pour moi la clé viendra de la
concurrence pour moi c'est parce que
vous mettra des écoles en concurrence
les unes avec les autres dans des accès
aux emplois publics qu'elle se quelques
là on aura de nouveau une nouvelle offre
plus plus plus plus intéressantes sur le
fond voilà mais en tout cas lorsque vous
dites que le que le classement de sortie
et tué sa suppression serait une bonne
chose pour bien comprendre qu'il n'est
pas supprimé c'est à dire que ce qui est
supprimée c'est l'accès direct aux
grands corps
sinon il faudrait classement
ils sont retirés du classement et donc
effectivement là pour répondre à votre
question je suis d'accord et vous il
faut pas que le destin soit fait à 25
ans
et il faut effectivement un passage par
le terrain parce que la crise
démocratique que nous vivons c'est une
crise dans laquelle les français ont
l'impression que les élites ne sont plus
redevable que des élites ne redonne pas
ce qu'elles ont reçues et en donnant
cinq ans de sa vie sigean de sa vie sur
le terrain en préfectorale je crois
qu'effectivement on a un élément de
réconciliation nationale et sera c'est
une bonne chose
donc on aura l'occasion évidemment d'en
reparler parce que c'est vrai que le
fond du problème derrière tout ça c'est
aussi celui la bureaucratie qui est qui
et qui est un des problèmes français
voudraient qu'on parle aussi de la
réforme d'injustice ou de quelques
aspects de cette réforme c'est le
troisième thème de cette émission
[Musique]
alors il ya beaucoup d'aspects yahia
notamment
d d d une réforme sur la remise de peine
automatiques qui seraient supprimés ce
qui est plutôt semble-t-il une bonne
chose ce qu'on voit pas pourquoi il ya
des remises de peine automatiques
qu'elles soient faites quand les gens se
comportent bien on peut comprendre que
la soie automatique c'est un peu moins
compréhensible mais ya deux sujets sur
lesquels on pourrait revenir le premier
c'est celui de la professionnalisation
d'une partie de la justice criminelle
c'est à dire qu'il y aura plus de jurés
pour les crimes qu'ils sont plus de 15 à
20 ans et met tout ça arrive laurent
basauri à un moment où il ya eu d'abord
une récidive d'un daim créées une aile
d'un violeur et puis ce jugement qui est
très contesté par les policiers
qui a été qu'ils sont très très léger
pour les pour les auteurs de deux de ce
crime est ce que finalement la confiance
puisque c'est ça le le but de ce projet
de la confiserie de la justice serait
pas aussi qui est des décisions qui
soient approuvées par tout le monde
alors je vais revenir alors vous avez
raison patrice alors là c'est un sujet
terrible pour l'investissement l'abord
d'abord il n'est jamais bon non plus de
légiférer dans des atmosphères justement
sous le feu de l'actualité parce que
évidemment les exemples qu'on a
récemment qui plus est je le rappelle on
vient d'avoir ce jugement effectivement
dans la sphère viry châtillon qui fait
suite à un appel reçu le prix
l'électricien comme premier jugement
n'était pas assez sévères on renvoie en
appel est la finale le deuxième jugement
qui pour le coup d'ailleurs des packs
avec des magistrats professionnels
puisqu'on en cour d'assises même si à 8o
se trouvait plus léger que la première
danse pour autant là encore bien j'en
suis désolé mais le rôle de politique
des politiques est essentielle les juges
les jurés s'exprime dans le cadre de la
loi cette loi édictée par le politique
d'accord et donc quand un juge pour une
décision il ne sort pas du cadre de la
loi on lui a juste donné la possibilité
de le faire alors on pourrait rediscuter
ont parlé tout à l'heure de nicolas
sarkozy une époque y avait ce qu'on
appelait les peines plancher qui était
une forme de palliatif aurait été sans
dire son nom ça permettait de remonter
effectivement les peines minimales pour
autant les jurés cette fin est toujours
et donc nous alors le point essentiel
c'est qu'il ne faut pas oublier quand
même que constitutionnellement essais
héritée de la révolution française la
loi s'est exprimée l'édition du si sont
prises au nom du peuple français et moi
ce qui me choquerait c'est d'avoir
effectivement que des tribunaux qui sera
les formes de tribunaux d'exception
bardet exclusivement de professionnels
qui ne rendrait pas justice au nom du
peuple français mais qui rendrait la
justice au nom d'une forme de caste
juridique qui dont on ne sait pas très
bien leur ont rejoint un peu le débat
précédent en fonction de quels la
politique
philosophie ils ont droit d'avoir leur
opinion ils ont droit d exprimer et il
serait normal qu'ils expriment
simplement je pense qu'on échapperait là
à la notion de jurys populaires qui est
quand même l'instance de base à mon sens
d'une vraie démocratie même si
l'adversaire est à plaire reste aux
internautes de conserver six mais ce qui
me choque c'est le mot pour un certain
nombre tout jury devrait être populaire
des leurres effectivement que la vie
humaine est mis en jeu il n'y a pas de
dossier les fictions ou que c'est le
peuple qui rend la justice mais ça file
alors pour moi ça veut dire que notre
conscient et une fiction et que la
réplique d'une fiction verser ces
hideuses
extra-professionnelles n'influence pas
beaucoup les gérer mais alors un autre
pourra effectivement quand vous mettez
12 personnes en colère ou pas dont
effectivement au sein d'un ordre d'un
local dans lequel y réfléchissez vous
avez un deux ou trois magistrats
professionnels bien sûr que l'influencé
existe mais le débat lui continue
coexister s'il n'ya plus que des avocats
entre eux et de pardon des juges entre
eux qu'ils se mettent d'accord il ya
plus de débat les et pour terminer on a
vu également le on voit le poids des
syndicats de la magistrature dans tout
ça est du syndicat de la magistrature on
remettrait donc les clés de la justice à
des organismes constitué non contrôlés
par la population mais mais franchement
alors là ce jeu vient d' extrême bourges
pour le coup je trouve que la justice
elle appartient et elle doit toujours
appartenir au peuple et pas des
spécialistes très clairement très
rapidement sur ces crs qu'il fallait un
peu vite très rapidement juste sur
l'histoire de viry-châtillon ce qui est
choquant et oui mais tout le monde fait
un amalgame en disant c'est scandaleux
d'aider des gens n'ont pas été condamnés
ça c'est la justice on n'a pas le
dossier sous les yeux ils sont passés
par ce qui peut en revanche est choquant
et je le sais tout à fait légitime que
les policiers se ses meubles c'est que
quelqu'un soit reconnu coupable et qui
prennent des peines relativement légères
pour avoir quand même essayé de brûler
vif des gens dans une voiture c'est ça
c'est la légèreté de la peine qui est
choquant que la moitié des prévenus soit
innocenté ou pas condamné c'est la
justice et son boulot je n'y connais
rien je n'ai pas le dossier celui mais
c'est vrai que les peines me paraissent
extrêmement élevé 16 celles suscitées en
tout cas la colère des milieux policiers
sur la sur la professionnalisation d'un
certain nombre de procédures criminelles
quel est votre sentiment de charlène
moi je voudrais déjà dire que je ne suis
pas complètement quand je suis même
totalement contre l'idée qu'on puisse
dire que la justice doit venir du peuple
parce que je dois rappeler quand même
que quand on a mis en place
l'étatisation de la justice à la fin du
moyen-âge c'était précisément pour
mettre fin aux écureuils dent pour dent
et aux querelles de tribus et de
populations qu'on pouvions avoir et je
trouve que c'est bien que nous ayons mis
fin à ce qu'on a tous pu lire en sixième
avec notre dame de paris à ces
exécutions sur la place de grève avec ce
plaisir très bas instincts finalement
que nous avons à avoir exécuté certaines
personnes je crois précisément que
l'étatisation le tiers neutre qu'est le
juge c'est toute notre théorie de la
procédure et tous le droit
constitutionnel d'ailleurs de notre
procédure que de confier à un tiers nos
litige donc moi je ne crois pas du tout
que la justice doit venir du peuple le
au nom du peuple français
mais par exemple la justice
administrative qui nous a quand même
très correctement défendu pendant la
crise sanitaire à propos des ddd des
masques des vaccins etc elle est rendue
par des juges professionnels avec
l'équipe d'avocats de tiers etc et on
n'a pas pour autant de sentiments que ça
devient un monopole léniniste de l'état
social donc je crois qu'il faut faire
attention avec le fait que la présence
de neuf jurés ne rend pas la justice
plus démocratique et la présence de
juges professionnels ne la rend pas plus
étatiques et je crois que nous avons
besoin d'une justice étatique qui
plaisent aux peuples et j'ajoute aussi
qu'il faut peut-être arrêter ces espèces
de querelles de calendrier en précisant
qu' une mois arrive en même temps qu'un
fait divers et que du coup on se demande
si elle va répondre à ce fait divers la
la justice ne pourra pas plaire à tous
demain qu'il s'agisse de la réponse de
la réforme du congrès ty de n'importe
quel autre puisque finalement on revient
là aussi à cette notion d'instinct c'est
à dire que la victime va pouvoir être
vengé les bébés tout le monde aura une
opinion sur toutes les décisions de
justice rendues et et laissons quand
même la justice travailler à tête
reposée moi je crois qu'ils voient là
c'est une bonne réforme en tout cas sur
certains points et la question la
professionnalisation c'est plus le fait
de perdre cette exception française qui
peut nous c'est un petit peu mais voilà
la la la la la mesure entre le peuple et
l'état elle est quand même très
démocratique est exemplaire en france
arthur de l'année vincent cordes très
rapidement est ce que justement il vaut
mieux pas une j-6 un peu plus rapide
qu'elle ne l'est plus tôt qu'une justice
qui en apparence démocratique et
populaire pour plaire à l'euro mazaury
on parle à mon avis du dû
malheureusement du détail enfin il ya
des problèmes plus profonds que ça
emmanuel macron avait promis la création
de 15000 places de prison on sait qu'on
parle plus sains et oui mais le problème
de la justice c'est pas des primes de
principe cas là c'est qu'on a une
justice du tiers-monde c'est une
injustice qui est smicard dirait une
justice qui n'a pas les moyens de faire
respecter l'ordre public parce que c'est
la première fois qu'une telle
augmentation du budget de la justice a
quand même d'accord mais où sont les
places de prison c'est dire les moyens à
un moment donné d'ajuster ça doit être
des murs des parents et des gens qui
tiennent
enfermé c'est tranquille en cause sur
d'une place de priso depuis que c'était
je crois chalandon qui était qu'elle
était garde des sceaux donc sa robe
courte
la deuxième cohabitation je crois avoir
lancé
le projet il faut des bonnes manger
désolé mais c'est comme ça c'est parce
que moyen
alors on va aborder juste très très
rapidement parce qu'on a réinterrogé nos
amis il est frustrant parce qu'on y
aurait beaucoup à dire en voyant la
mission c'est vrai on va y revenir mais
justement il ya dans cette réforme les y
aller les audiences fille mais alors
qu'est-ce qui est qu'est ce qu'ils ont
pensé nos amis de tout à l'heure j'ai à
faire
[Musique]
je suis pour pourquoi je pense que c'est
déjà un exemple on a besoin de cet
exemple pour que nos enfants aillent pas
aussi loin
premièrement deuxièmement ben ça nous
permet de voir entre cassis un geste i
saw pas ça permettrait je suppose enfin
c'est mon impression de comprendre un
petit peu les arguments des uns des
autres et voir un peu comment la justice
est rendue en fait se faire une opinion
plus concrètes que ce que l'on voit à
travers les émissions ou ce qu'on lit
draps presse je suis contre la diffusion
des procès c'est parce que je pense que
c'est on ne devrait plus élevé à près de
l'intimité l'image en fait d'aider des
prévenus et même des juges qui est
qui qui siège pendant ce procès ils ont
besoin à prétendre je pense je pense
qu'on a besoin d'eux qui passe inaperçu
en fait les procès c'est quand même
quelque chose d'opaque 11 on a des
comptes rendus de presse mais on sait
pas trop ce qu'est ce qui s'y passe
précisément que cela passe à la télé oui
après quelle chaîne publique accepterait
de les passer est ce que ça intéresse
les gens c'est une autre histoire je
suis formellement contre je ne vois pas
l'intérêt
pour moi c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui doit être réglé
entre quatre murs le public n'a rien à
faire dans cette histoire alors ben
voilà on a le champ des possibles c'est
à dire certains qui disent bah oui ça va
nous apprendre quelque chose d'autre ils
disent il faut préserver quand même à
l'intimité des gens qui passent en
procès et c'est vrai que c'est un c'est
un vrai problème quoi
tous les gens qui disent c'est
merveilleux on pourrait voir comment ça
se passe je rappelle que tous les virer
tous les procès sont publiques ici les
gens sont passionnés ils ont gagné à
l'est il ya toute la journée les procès
partout en france on pousse la porte
c'est obligatoire la panthère est
ouverte on y va et c'est tout alors
voyeurisme ou oct démocratique la
diffusion des procès indienne
rabin ont rejoint jean charles lajoie ni
la de justice elle est déjà puni qu'en
france ça ça fait partie des eaux des
principes d'organisation posées par les
textes internationaux de tous les
standards démocratiques donc on rajoute
de la télévision
si si ça peut
nourrir le débat
avec la vie qui a été donné par le
conseil d'état la turquie a dit voilà le
risque c'est après deux d'en faire un
petit peu une photo nisation donc
regardons cela pour l'information mais
ça ne gêne pas plus que ça puisqu'elle
est déjà publiques pour moi notre
justice la seule couronne
où il rapidement l'autre est juste le
paradoxe en fait qui revient à
sortir des jurés des cours d'assises et
pipoliser la justice en faisant rentrer
le thé les téléspectateurs donc il ya
effectivement probablement ici un
glissement qui se ferait donc d'une
justice en fait plus populaires
peut-être ou au sens avec des avec des
téléspectateurs qui pourra regarder je
précise quand même que cette ces procès
s'ils sont filmés
ne serait diffusée que après la fin
avec certains des interventions sur le
fait que c'est pas forcément une bonne
idée dans le sens où la justice comme le
diane charlène bezina elle est déjà
public les journalistes le public peut
déjà y assister et les films et ça peut
être comment dire mettre une sorte de de
pression à la fois sur les témoins on
rentre aussi dans l'intimité aussi des
différents partis ou des personnes qui
sont parties prenantes dans le procès
vous savez quand j'étais quand j'étais
élève au lycée j'ai eu de la chance
parce que pendant trois ans de la
seconde à la terminale je n'avais pas
cours le vendredi matin et pendant trois
ans tous les matins je suis allé
assister aux séances de correctionnelle
de ma vie tous les matins tous les
vendredis matin j'étais et c'est là
qu'on voit en fait réellement qu'on
rentre dans l'intimité de la vie des
personnes cc c'est c'est plutôt
intéressant parce que c'est la fin de
l'émission le juste pardon
arthur un redevable
le micro ça y est je suis là n'en disait
que paf film et c'est très bien on est
ravi mais que les procès soit filmé non
ça c'est un manque de dignité et puis
c'est un simple d'un syndrome
supplémentaires
malheureusement de ce qu'on fait quand
on ne sait pas quoi faire voilà on
invente un luxe a fait parler mais je
vois pas en quoi les français si on
travaille davantage en sécurité parce
qu'on aura mis des caméras dans les
salles d'audience a annoncé me semble
on aura l'occasion probablement de
reparler parce qu'il ya aussi beaucoup
d'autres choses dans cette réforme de la
justice et vous avez raison il n'ya pas
le problème des places de prison merci
merci à tous les quatre randonneurs
douanes je rappelle que bâle à l'appel
du projet vauban qui s'appelle la france
a besoin d'un état stratège pas d'un
état brancardier on peut le retrouver
dans le figaro figaro vox merci beaucoup
l'auront mazaury merci beaucoup de
chercheurs de la joie ni c'est moi qu'il
veut c'est votre dernier roman mais on
n'a plus le temps de parler demandant à
chaque fois à chaque fois merci beaucoup
un terminal nucléaire merci beaucoup
vincent quorum merci beaucoup arthur 2
et à très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
boeuf
[Musique]